Prof: Today we will
begin Purgatorio which is
a word meaning place of
cleansing,
purification and is the middle
section of the poem,
literally a place of transition
between the world of Hell,
and all the evil that we have
witnessed,
and then, the realm of glory
which is going to be Paradise.
Let me say a few things about
Purgatory, both as an idea and
as a poetic construction,
Dante's poetic construction.
As an idea, the way Dante
understands it,
Purgatory is part of human
geography.
As you know,
it's located in the southern
hemisphere.
There are two hemispheres in
medieval geography:
the northern hemisphere,
which is the one we inhabit,
and then there is the southern
hemisphere,
and Purgatory is an island.
I have tried to explain to you
last time the origin of this
place.
In Dante's medieval poetic
thinking it's an island that
emerged from the northern
hemisphere at the time of
Lucifer's fall.
The earth trembles and
retreats, that's the idea,
as Lucifer approaches and thus
it creates the void which
becomes Hades,
the abyss, and the island--and
the Purgatory emerges on the
other side,
in the southern hemisphere.
At the top of the Purgatory,
there is the island--there
is--the peak is the Garden of
Eden, there where God placed
Adam and Eve.
So that from this point of
view, Purgatory is part of human
geography, but it's historically
inaccessible to human beings.
One hero that we already met,
Ulysses,
in Inferno XXVI,
tries to approach an island and
retrospectively,
we can understand that that was
the island of Purgatory as if it
were a place of immortality that
Ulysses wanted to reach and
could not.
That journey of his ended in
shipwreck and tragically.
Inferno XXVI is the text for
that kind of concern.
The other trait about
Purgatory, a moral trait,
since this is now--we are going
to enter the realm of
reconstruction of the human and
this sort of makes of sense that
Dante should place it
immediately after Hell.
It is as if only by knowing,
only by experiencing more or
less,
as metaphorically as we can,
through the poetry of Dante,
the nature of evil and the
horror of it,
can we begin to have an
appreciation of the good.
The good toward which--now the
pilgrim is going to climb.
The other thing that you should
keep in mind about Purgatory,
and the difficulties that the
poet will have,
is the following.
The perception of moral life
and political life in Inferno
was so satanic,
so narrow, so terrible that
Dante's going to have a lot of--
quite a challenge to try to
explain the usefulness and the
possibility of reconstructing a
moral world, then the political
world.
He came very close to a total
rejection of the historical
world and the political world,
and now he has to find out how
that reconstruction is going to
be possible.
The way he will do this is,
literally, to go back to the
natural world.
Do not expect Dante to imagine
a place where there is some kind
of redemptive intervention from
the outside that can tell us,
this is the way you do it.
The natural world must be
capable of producing within
itself some--at least contain
some seeds for a need to
reconstruct--for a need for the
good.
This is going to be part of his
strategy and his difficulties.
A further trait of
Purgatory which was
really completely missing in
Inferno,
we had never had a sense of
time.
Time was the biological clock
of the pilgrim who was the only
living creature,
the only truly displaced
figure, and he is the only
displaced figure throughout the
poem.
In Purgatorio he will
find--in Purgatorio,
they're all displaced figures.
So it's a more human world,
but here, now,
they have this sense of time.
In fact, the first thing that
we come to understand is
how--what time is.
It's time understood as future
oriented,
as a projection in some kind of
future,
and, at the same time,
this idea of time also turns
out to be a return to the past.
So that as the pilgrim is going
ahead,
he really discovers that he's
going backwards to the Garden of
Eden: exactly there where Adam
and Eve were placed at the top
of Purgatory by God at the
time--
in the story that you have in
Genesis,
for instance.
This idea of time,
this will become truly a
leitmotif throughout Purgatory.
The idea of what is the
relationship between the past
and the future,
since the only real time is
really the future from that
point of view,
which makes you understand that
even the past was the future at
some point, at least right?
The future is the only thing
that Dante is going to be
interested in and the future
will come in the possibility of
a future,
and the way it's related to the
past will become the object of
his concerns,
the object of his thinking
openly as he goes through the
various ledges of Purgatory.
Poetically, the
Purgatory is divided into
two--into three parts,
I would say actually.
The first part is the so-called
anti-Purgatory,
made of souls who are waiting.
They're not really penitent
yet, but waiting to be assigned
a particular place along the
ledges.
And then, the so-called
penitents before going through
the process of cleansing,
beginning with pride,
and ending up with lechery at--
just before the pilgrim gets
into the Garden of Eden.
The ordering of sins is the
exact reversal of the ordering
of sins you had in Inferno.
Here you begin with a spiritual
sin or intellectual sin,
the question of pride,
and end up with the most
physical and material of them
all,
lechery, which as you recall is
the inverted image of what
happened in Inferno with Lucifer
and the sin of Lucifer being
really a sin of pride at the end
of Canto XXIV.
Well, having said this maybe
other things will come to mind
as I go on today.
Let me begin with some other--a
couple of details as I--just as
I get into--plunge into Canto I.
What is the pilgrim now?
The poem--the journey began on
Good Thursday,
as it's called.
Dante spends the first night
but the journey--
the real journey begins on Good
Friday in a clear imitation of
Christ's harrowing of Hell and
emergence into the light on
Easter Sunday.
That's where we are now,
Easter Sunday morning.
If the Inferno begins at dusk
therefore, the idea of the
approaching night that stands
for the unknowability of
whatever he is going to
confront.
Dante's fascinated with the
idea of the night throughout
Inferno.
Imagine--remember Ulysses who
travels following the sun and
then ends up really gazing at
the night,
the unknowability of his
destiny, the unknowability of
the place even where he is.
Now we begin with dawn and
therefore Canto I of Purgatorio
becomes that which in
Provençal literature is
called an aubade,
from the word,
aube, alba in Italian,
aubade.
The song--the dawn song,
a song that in many ways
reverses the grand tradition of
the erotic lyrics of
Provençal poetry where
the dawn becomes the unhappy
time for the parting of lovers
and here now its regained as the
great time when,
finally, the pilgrim can go on
and the poet can go on mapping,
literally now mapping the
journey, sailing through or
sending as the metaphor that he
asks--
that he adopts can be.
The poem--the second part of
the poem,
Purgatorio begins,
first of all,
with an image of water and
therefore it carries further
this motif of the cleansing and
purification,
but really with a better
metaphor from our point of view.
"To course over better
waters the little bark of my wit
now lifts her sails,
leaving behind her so cruel a
sea, and I will sing of that
second kingdom where the human
spirit is purged and becomes fit
to ascend to Heaven.
But here let poetry rise again
from the dead,
O holy Muses,
since I am yours;
and here let Calliope rise up
for a while and accompany my
song with that strain which
smote the ears of the wretched
pies so that they despaired of
pardon."
It's an extraordinary proem to
Purgatorio,
for a number of reasons.
First of all,
Dante picks up the metaphor of
the epic topos,
the epic metaphor of the
journey with which the poem
began,
'in the middle of the journey
of our life,' as you recall.
But now this idea of the
process as indicated with--first
of all, it's sailing,
therefore literally recalling
the sea voyage of Ulysses.
That's an oblique metaphor.
I want to draw your attention
to the use of this adjective--
a comparative adjective--that's
what we call it in grammar,
as you recall:
"the better waters."
It's just Dante's emphasis,
exactly on the process and then
the comparatively good.
This is not the best of waters;
it's not the worst of waters;
this is the better waters.
We are really on the way to
better things.
It's a world of degree that
Dante introduces.
Dante really believes in a sort
of hierarchy and a hierarchy of
values, of states,
of powers, of beauty,
of intellect.
The world cannot be--it's never
a dualistic world between what's
bad and what's good.
There's a lot of mediations,
meditating steps along the way,
and now he already introduces
this whole question with the
notion of the better waters.
"The little bark"
with its--this is not only a
journey;
this is a journey of poetry.
It is as if Dante now wants to
highlight a motif which is going
to be very crucial throughout
the poem and in our reading of
this poem.
That the reading of this poem,
and I have been addressing this
issue to some of your questions,
that there really is no sharp,
no drastic discontinuity
between the journey of the
pilgrim and the journey of the
poet.
That the journey of the poet is
an extension;
it, in itself,
is a journey--in of itself is a
journey of knowledge and the
journey of discovery.
Dante makes large claims for
poetry: poetry is a way of
knowing.
It's just not a
re-commemoration of the past.
Now here, he talks about the
journey as being the journey of
the poet, "the little bark
of my wit."
It's a conventional way of
thinking about the bark of
poetry with which he is--
there seems to be a way of
saying this is now more--
at this stage,
at least, he wants us to think
about the journey of poetry and
not just the journey that he
himself will use--
will undertake the journey of
the pilgrim,
the hard, difficult journey
filled with fear that he was
experiencing in Inferno.
I also want to draw your
attention to another little
detail of the text.
This is--the first time now
that Dante will use the future
tense.
"I will sing."
We're in a world open to
futurity and,
if it's open to futurity,
the only way of thinking about
futurity is made possible by a
belief in the new.
You have to--you cannot really
think--yes, you can think of the
future, but if the future is
exactly as it is today,
then you really have no future.
Then you really think that all
is released into the domain of
sameness.
If my day today is exactly
what--the world that I
experienced yesterday,
there's no new,
no idea of the new.
And Dante: here,
uses the future,
and clearly implying that there
is an alternative,
a difference,
a possibility of doing things
in ways that have not been done
before.
This is going to be a new
departure,
a new departure for thought,
a new departure for the
imagination,
and now he says it has to be
also a new departure for poetry
itself.
I emphasize this idea of the
future "will sing."
The first time that he--he
wasn't saying this in
Inferno,
of course he couldn't even say
that in the Vita nuova.
You remember that I pointed out
when we were reading that little
autobiographical,
great, text called the Vita
nuova, at the beginning of the
term,
I indicated to you that there
is never the future tense used
in that text.
It was all a book of memory
with the difficulties and the
dangers of memory.
The dangers of memory being
that memory changes,
can draw us into a world of
phantasms.
That's one of the--it's not a
rejection of memory,
only a way of highlighting its
possible dangers.
And the belief that unless you
live with some idea of danger,
maybe we're not really thinking
hard enough.
Here now it's the--the only
time that the future was used in
the Vita nuova was either in the
idea of death,
when Dante has a prophetic
dream and he hears a voice that
he perceives as a kind of soul.
So truth laden it is in that
voice that he thinks of it as a
kind of prophecy,
as a sort of oracle speaking to
him: you too will die.
Beatrice has just died and then
the death of Beatrice brings to
his mind the fear and threat of
mortality to him.
You too will die:
that's the way the future is
going to be understood.
Then the poem,
the whole Vita nuova ends with
a statement of hope,
and hope to work and write
things whereby I can say things
about Beatrice that had never
been said about any woman and so
that becomes the two
possibilities of the future.
The only--literally once
grammatically the future tense
and the other with--
through this periphrastic
construction,
this oblique construction about
the hope,
the verb use of the hope
in--with the idea of the future
indicated there.
Then, "but here let poetry
rise again from the dead,"
and the prayer to the muses,
very much in the style of the
epic tradition and especially of
the muses,
to want the muse of epic
poetry, Calliope.
Then the focus of Calliope will
really tell you something about
the kind of--
think retrospectively really
explains,
"but let dead poetry rise
again from the dead."
The poem presents itself as
Calliope, was the mother of
whom?
Anybody remember?
Remember your mythology?
Okay, no you don't now,
but it's the mother of Orpheus,
so let dead poetry rise again
from the dead it's--
Dante presents himself as he
were an orphic poet.
He was not an orphic poet,
but it's really a poet in the
tradition of Orpheus who wants
to conquer death;
that's clearly not for him,
that's what the Orpheus descent
into the underworld really is
the way of conquering death.
The belief that poetry can do
the trick,
that through poetry we
immortalize ourselves,
we conquer death,
he is going to very soon to
understand that that's not the
way he is going to do that.
Then something in the second
paragraph I want to read it a
little bit,
because it really gives you a
different sense of the tonality
of Purgatorio,
because not only do you have
now morning and time,
you also for the first time
have light.
Not the sort of spectacular
shades of light,
the blue, the reds,
the green with which he
experiences and dramatizes
Paradise according to the
lights emanating from the
various planets,
the red of Mars,
the white of Jupiter,
the blue of Saturn and so there
is a kind of polychromic palette
that is going to be deployed.
Here it's now a more human and
natural world,
the natural world,
and listen to this and this
enables me to say something else
about the traits of Purgatorio.
"The sweet hue of the
oriental sapphire which was
gathering the serene face of the
heavens from the clear zenith to
the first circle,
gladdened my eyes again as soon
as I passed out of the dead air
which had afflicted my eyes and
breast.
The fair planet that prompts
to," Venus,
the morning star,
"to love made all the east
laugh,
veiling the Fishes which were
in her train.
I turned to the right."
You remember that I sort of
tried to explain to you that,
with one exception that I can't
explain,
nobody can explain,
and very few people have
noticed the--
Dante is now turning to the
right, which is to say that even
while going down,
spiraling down in the world of
Hell he actually was going to
the right.
Though he said that he was
going to the left,
and he was going to the left
because he was upside down.
Now he is right side up and so
the directions of the human
world are going to be regained.
"I turned to the
right," he will never use
this image again,
"and set my mind on the
other pole,
and I saw four stars never seen
before but by the first
people,"
Adam and Eve.
"The skies seem to rejoice
in their flames.
O widowed region of the north,
since thou art denied that
sight!"
The northern hemisphere is
where we are.
Dante's in the southern
hemisphere.
He is connecting with us,
telling us what we are deprived
of in--by not knowing,
by having lost Paradise.
A couple of things that I will
not--since Dante will go back to
these images.
The way he literally orients
himself: the metaphor he uses is
that of--
is the oriental light,
and the way he's always
orienting or reorienting
himself.
How do you know where you are,
is now in Purgatorio and also
in Paradise,
when thinking about characters
here on earth and recalling
their lives it's always by
looking at the east.
It's always by looking in the
light of the east,
and from this point of view
Dante really retrieves that most
incredible metaphor that is
available among the mystics,
medieval mystics,
and I'm thinking--
or thinkers.
I'm thinking of even Boethius,
Cassiodorus--
I hope they're not just names
for you--
who think--who believe that you
can only think,
that we in the west,
the western light,
can only think by looking
toward the east.
That the way in which we can be
orienting ourselves is by trying
to capture the source of that
light.
I mean this in the most
metaphorical,
and as we shall see,
the widest senses possible,
but that's all he is saying
now.
But at the same time,
in the language,
it's incredible how it has
shifted between the first
paragraph and the second
paragraph.
That which seems to be the
excitement for the light,
and now he's experiencing
again;
it's Easter Sunday.
He understands the
Resurrection,
this is going to hit him very
strongly now,
but it's also an elegiac--the
tonality is elegiac,
the idea of what we have lost,
the widowed region of the
northern hemisphere,
the sense of general loss,
though it's a provisional
privilege for him to see all
this,
but this indicates and
introduces that the
extraordinary tension,
poetic tension in
Purgatory.
The dialectic between
excitement for the future and an
elegy for the past.
The pilgrim is caught in
between and we shall see the
consequences between--
this is still at the level of
tonality I would call it,
but we shall see what this
really means in a moment.
As Dante approaches now,
"When I have withdrawn my
gaze," and so on.
This is line 25:
"When I have withdrawn my
gaze from them,"
turning to the stars,
"turning a little toward
the other pole,
where the Wain had already
disappeared,
I saw beside me an old man
alone, worthy by his looks of so
great reverence that no son owes
more to a father;
his beard was long and streaked
with white, and his hair the
same, a double tress falling on
his breast,"
etc.
This is going to be the
encounter with Cato and I want
to talk about Cato.
Let me just give you a little
bit of extra Dantesque
information.
I mean in a way,
this is--you probably do not
know that this representation,
we call this descriptio of the
old man with the beard or
white--
streaked with white but on two
sides really is the paradigm--
the model that Michelangelo
writes--
Michelangelo follows in his
conception of Moses.
Though Dante doesn't lose sight
of the fact that this is Cato.
Just a little piece of how
Michelangelo read this
particular meeting.
Who is this Cato?
Dante describes him as an old
man, and we also know that he's
a Roman.
He's a pagan,
and he's not only a pagan,
he's a man of laws.
The first thing that he wonders
and he says,
paragraph, "Who are ye
that I have fled,"
these are just people who have
tried to literally escape from
prison,
"the eternal prison
against the blind stream?'
he said..
.'Who has guided you or who was
your lantern in coming forth
from profound night that holds
in perpetual blackness the
valley of Hell?
Are the laws of the abyss thus
broken,"
this is the Roman tradition of
the law,
"are there laws of the
abyss."
In a way this is a man who is a
stranger to the world of
Purgatory.
He certainly doesn't seem to
understand the heaven may have
been some grace that maybe Dante
and his guide are here out of
some providential intervention
which is not to be explained by
laws or by natural,
or by the laws of nature,
or by manmade laws.
"Are the laws of the abyss
broken or has a new
decree,"
he wonders,
"been made in heaven that,
being damned,
you come to my cliffs?'
My leader," Virgil.
The two Romans talk now and I
who myself, "Then answered
him: 'Of myself,
I came not.
A lady,"
Beatrice, a recapitulation of
Inferno I,
"descended from Heaven for
whose prayers I succoured this
man with my companionship;
but since this is thy will to
have it made more plain how in
truth it stands with us,
it cannot be mine to deny thee.
This man never saw his last
hour, but by his folly was so
near to it that little time was
left to run.
I was sent to him ...
I have shown him all the guilty
race and now purpose to show him
those spirits that cleanse
themselves under thy charge.
How I have led him would be
long to tell thee;
there descends from above
virtue which aids me in bringing
him to see thee and to hear
thee.
May it please thee to be
gracious to his coming.
He goes seeking liberty which
is so dear, as he knows who
gives his life for it."
And the reference is clearly to
Cato himself who,
historically--a historical
figure--actually committed
suicide in the civil war and
refusing to take sides between
Pompey and Caesar,
as is told in the great epic by
Lucan,
the Roman Spanish poet,
who wrote the so-called Civil
War.
A text that is very polemical,
in between-among other
things--with Virgil.
"Thou knowest it,
since death for it was no
bitter to thee in Utica,"
in North Africa,
"where thou didst leave
the vesture,"
the body,
"which in the great day
will be so bright.
The eternal edicts are not
broken for us,
for this man lives and Minos
does not bind me;
but I am of the circle,"
Limbo,
"where are the chased eyes
of thy Marcia,"
his wife,
"who in her looks still
prays thee,
O holy breast,
that thou hold her for thine
own.
For her love,
then, do thou incline to us,
allow us to go through thy
seven kingdoms.
I will report to her thy
kindness if thou deign to be
spoken of there below."
And he responds,
"Marcia so pleased my eyes
while I was yonder,' he said
then,
"that whatever kindness
she sought of me I did;
now that she dwells beyond the
evil stream she cannot move me
more, by the law which was made
when I came forth from thence.
But if a lady," etc.
This is an amazing from--in
substantial terms,
an amazing beginning in the
poem because Dante meets Cato
whom he defines--
we are being told there that
he's an old man,
a pagan, and a suicide.
There are traits that Virgil
singles out,
obliquely referring to his
adventures and that clearly
contradict the world of
Purgatory,
because the Purgatory is a
Christian canticle.
This is Easter Sunday,
why have it inaugurated by the
presence of the pagan who knew
nothing of the incarnation?
Why have it--it's the Rome of a
renewed life,
why start it with a suicide?
Someone who--we saw what Dante
thought of the suicides when--
in a complicated way throughout
Inferno,
there were a number of suicides
inhabiting various aspects of--
various regions of Hell,
but especially among the--
with the violent against nature
Inferno XIII and so,
an old man, a suicide,
and a pagan:
why does he do this?
A figure that he draws out of
the world of Lucan;
what we are told about him this
is--
usually whenever you have
representations of the beyond,
you always have a young man,
for instance a juvenis,
or this is a character,
the Latin term meaning the
young,
in Alain de Lille for example
there's always a young man or a
young woman who is welcoming to
indicate the renewed life,
the novelty,
the freshness of a life.
You certainly don't have an old
man and you certainly do not
have a suicide.
Now the question of the suicide
is probably the easiest to
determine because Cato's suicide
is a suicide for freedom.
Let me say a couple of things
about freedom because it's--I
call Purgatory,
really, the domain of freedom.
It's really the place of
freedom.
He begins here explaining,
as it were, a political,
but also moral state.
It's political because it's a
refusal of the disarray and
chaos brought in by the war
between Pompey and Caesar,
at the time of the civil war,
but it is also a moral state,
because Cato decides to put an
end to his life in a sort of
sacrificial move;
as if to draw attention to the
way in which the state had been
killed,
had been destroyed by the
rivalry between these two great
figures who have not opposed,
but have a rivalry about power.
Freedom is to the fundamental
problem, it's a Roman issue let
me just say.
Dante wants us to think of it
at the very beginning of
Purgatorio,
in pagan intellectual terms,
freedom.
The whole Purgatory ends
up with the pilgrim regaining
and being crowned,
as he'll say,
with the attainment of free
will,
so the whole poem really moves
this idea of Cato's search for
freedom,
press for freedom,
and the pilgrim's attainment of
free will.
Now there is an obvious
relationship to begin with
between freedom,
on the one hand,
and, I would say,
the future on the other.
The poem begins with the future
and now we are going to be said
what are they--what is the
virtue of the future?
You cannot conceive of freedom,
unless you have an idea of the
future.
You cannot--you understand the
connection between the two?
You cannot conceive of a
novelty unless you have an idea
of the future and unless you
have idea of freedom.
The notion of originality is
actually, even poetic
originality, is impossible,
unless it's tied to a certain
idea of freedom.
It presupposes them all,
so that the attainment of
freedom really means poetic
originality, the idea of the
future.
The notion that things can be
different.
If I am slave to the past,
if I am a slave to a political
order,
if I am slave to my own vices,
as internalized as that quest
can be,
then I really have no freedom.
Cato embodies one who refuses
living--
if living means living in a
state of tyranny to civil war,
violence, and therefore to the
impossibility of a moral life.
That's easy to determine,
that's easy to explain.
I even think that the notion of
the old man can be explained.
Dante wants to draw our
attention, first of all,
that somehow the search for the
future,
he's--it's not an alternative
to the past,
it grows out of the past so
that we--
he's rejecting the idea that
there may be some sharp
distinction between the two and
that the seeds of the future are
already contained in the past,
in a figure such as an old man,
Cato.
The third problem is the
question his being a pagan,
and this brings me back to that
which is the project,
Dante's project,
in Purgatorio.
The project is that there
is--he must make a careful
distinction, which St.
Augustine could not make in the
City of God.
Dante will make it,
that's his--that's Dante's
target, polemical target.
Augustine really distinguishes
between the earthly city and the
heavenly city.
And the heavenly city may live
on earth, but it's really a
pilgrim church going on toward
the beatitude and the encounter
with God.
The earthly city is corrupt and
in many ways not assimilable to
the world of the Redemption.
This--if you are an Augustinian
and you have very supple view of
Augustine--
may strike you as crude,
but I don't think that it
really violates the essence of
that dual idea between the
earthly city and the heavenly
city.
Dante is literally talking
against the Augustinian dualism.
There is in nature,
that is within the pagan
secular historical world,
there are seeds that can become
crucial for the making of the
political,
for the making of a new moral
life that will be really
consonant with,
not dissonant with,
in accord with the Redemption,
and the Christian Redemption,
that he will be actually
seeking.
Keep this very much in mind.
A sign of this incredible
tension--
time, the meaning of freedom,
the value of the pagan world,
the insistence on the secular
as capable of producing some
kind of seed for the future--
emerges really in the second
paragraph,
when finally Virgil,
to bend to the harshness,
to temper the harshness of
Cato, says look,
let us go through because I
know your wife.
Very Italian,
I know your wife and I'm going
to go very back,
that is to say I know who you
are so do me a favor because
I'll be doing her a favor,
let me go and Marcia--let
Marcia--I will go there and they
will tell her what a great man
you are,
what a good man you are.
What he is doing he's appealing
to Cato's effective memory and
it is an appeal,
it's a solicitation that Cato
refuses.
She can do nothing for me:
he refuses to be determined by
the past.
You see the ambiguities that
are running through.
Dante understands that you have
to go through some other poet
and the figuration understands
that you cannot really have a
sense of the future without
being rooted in the past and
then here you have Cato who can
only make sharp distinctions,
she can do nothing about me.
I could tell you that this is a
very--
the appeal to Marcia's memory
for Cato can become also--
is full of ironies and I will
only tell you--
we can't--it would take us too
far afield,
I can tell you that in effect,
in the history of Cato,
Marcia had left.
She had asked Cato to divorce
her because she wanted to marry
somebody else,
and at the death of the other
husband Marcia asks Cato to take
her and he will.
And Dante is--Dante recounts
this whole story in the
Banquet and views it as a
sign of the extraordinary
generosity of this man.
There is all of that lore in
the background of this reference
to Cato,
but from our point of view
then, it is a question of the
power of memory and the limits
of memory.
And then finally the--he will
go on saying--
giving some--Cato will go on
giving some rules that he has to
follow in the process of
cleansing: you go and wash
yourself from the stain of
Inferno,
he will tell him,
and gird your loins.
They will be there.
He will mention and go to the
desert shore,
therefore go and--this is the
last paragraph:
"The dawn,"
here is the dawn song,
"was overcoming the
morning breeze which fled before
it,
so that I descried far off the
trembling of the sea.
We made our way over the lonely
plain, like one who returns to
the road he has lost and,
until he finds it,
seems to himself to go in vain.
When we were at a part where
the dew resists the sun and,
being in shade,
is little dispersed,
my Master gently laid both
hands outspread on the grass.
I, therefore,
aware of his purpose reached
toward him my tear-stained
cheeks."
That's the ritual of
purification which he,
the pilgrim,
must undergo.
"..
.and on them he wholly restored
the color which Hell had hidden
in me.
We came then on the desert
shore that never saw men sail
its waters, who after had
experience of return."
Whom are you suppose to
overhear here?
What is the reference to?
Anybody?
Absolutely, he makes it very
clear that Cato and Ulysses are
the two pagans.
There is a difference:
he intrudes--he insinuates a
distinction within the body of
pagan culture.
Ulysses, on the one hand,
and his own transgressive
search for knowledge,
in the belief that really there
is no knowledge without
transgression,
which is considerable and would
be worth considering,
and on the other hand,
the experience of Cato himself.
Now we are here with a
different pagan.
"There he girded me as the
other had bidden."
That's a phrase that comes
straight out of Inferno XXVI.
"O marvel!
for as was the lowly plant he
chose such did it spring up
again immediately in the place
where he had plucked it."
So Dante has to gird himself
the way journeymen would
whenever they undertake a
journey in antiquity.
Whether it is the biblical
journeyman or the Romans--the
gird--they put this girdle
around themselves.
They gird their loins.
It's a moment of containment of
self and that's the ritual he
has to undergo.
From my point of view,
though, the emphasis falls on
the power of the natural world
to restore itself,
because immediately--and there
is an emblem of the Resurrection
here now,
but we're still in the natural
world.
There is no element of grace:
the nature of the plant--in an
inversion of what had happened
in Inferno XIII--the plant
is--rises again,
is born again.
And now we come to Canto II.
The situation changes somewhat,
but let me just begin another
point of--
it starts with another search
for orientation and I mean that
in--
it's an easy pun.
The east, the Orient,
and orientation for the pilgrim
and now it becomes more clearly
Jerusalem,
and we'll see the reason why
it's going to be Jerusalem,
in a moment.
Well, one reason why,
let me just say it immediately
because it has nothing to do
with the--
this has to do more with let's
say the myth rather than with
the text,
is that Hell and that Purgatory
is at the antipodes of
Jerusalem,
against the feet of Jerusalem.
Jerusalem was known as the
navel of the earth and now we
are in its--in Purgatory at its
antipodes.
It starts, "Already the
sun had reached the horizon,
whose meridian circle covers
Jerusalem,"
so Jerusalem will become the
point of reference,
"with its highest point,
and night, circling opposite to
it,
was issuing from the Ganges
with the Scales,
which fall from her hand when
she exceeds the day..."
etc.
"I was,
white with rosy cheeks of fair
Aurora, with her increasing age,
were turning orange.
We were still beside the sea,
like those that ponder on the
road, who go in heart and in
body linger."
An extraordinary image of this
location of being both being
body and mind and aware of a
break between the two,
who have expectations and hopes
of moving ahead,
and yet, they are kept in place
by the heaviness of the body.
"And lo as on the approach
of morning Mars grows ruddy
through the thick vapors low in
the west over the ocean floor,
so appeared to me--may I see it
again!--
a light coming so swiftly over
the sea that no flight could
match its speed."
Here he sees a boat,
a fast boat bringing,
carrying the souls of penitents
who are reaching the banks of
Purgatory.
The very opposite of what we
saw with Charon's boat in Hell,
the boat of,
you remember,
of the sinful souls.
And then an angel of God,
"Then as the divine bird
came towards us more and more,
he appeared brighter,
so that my eyes could not
bear," line 38,
"I cast them down and he
came on the shore with a vessel
so swift and light that the
water took in nothing of it.
On the poop stood the heavenly
steersman such that blessedness
seemed written upon him,
and more than a thousand
spirits sat within."
And they sing a psalm,
"In exitu Israel de
Aegypto"--Psalm,
according to the Vulgate,
113.
It's the psalm in which the
Jews are remembering their
exodus from the bondage,
the slavery in Egypt to
Jerusalem.
That's really the story.
This book of Exodus,
"In exitu Israel de
Aegypto."
You understand retrospectively
the reference to Jerusalem that
gives a kind of unity to this
whole canto.
It's a psalm that--there are a
number of things about this.
It's the only text that Dante
sites, textually cites.
He might make references to the
Bible all the time,
but the only text of the Bible
that Dante really cites
literally and takes from
textually,
is always the Book of Psalms.
Probably an acknowledgment that
it's poetry and that he responds
to that poetry;
but especially,
he does so, not only because--
it's probably the text
where--for the first time,
we have a representation of
subjectivity in Western
countries.
It's the story of someone who
is looking inward and finding
out the diseases of self,
the appetites,
the passions,
etc.
That may be one reason,
since he's engaged in that kind
of--he himself,
that pilgrim--is engaged in
that sort of quest.
But there is another reason,
I believe, because the Psalms
are basically lyrical
recapitulations of the story of
Exodus.
Dante's saying that Exodus is
the figure,
that the Divine Comedy is the
lyrical representation of the
story,
the biblical story of Exodus,
that he too--
that this human history is
engaged in that search,
a search from slavery to
liberty.
Let me just pursue this a
little bit, from another point
of view.
In Canto I of Purgatorio
we saw that it was a vision of
Roman political,
moral liberty.
Now we have an idea that the
whole of history is really
engaged in this exodus,
a journey toward liberty.
Two types of liberties:
a Roman one and a Jewish one,
to which Dante wants to
connect.
It is as if he understands that
there are two traditions,
both of which are based on a
quest for liberty.
That there is a sense of,
in both of them,
though in different ways,
a sense of beginning that he
must try to harmonize,
he must try to explore and
probe in depth.
What do they mean and what are
they about?
One, a kind of legal idea,
moral, political idea of
liberty--
Cato--that comes to the point
of self-destruction,
and the other one,
the question of spiritual
exodus.
By the way, a second thing I
can say about this reference to
Psalm 113 is that Dante uses it
as the basis for explaining his
use of allegory.
You remember that I spoke about
the allegory of poets and
allegory of theologians?
And that the difference was the
historical basis of the
narrative?
The story of Exodus for Dante
is historically true:
it's an event.
So this gives a kind of
biblical, figural aura to
Dante's representation--his
allegorical representation,
at least.
The third thing that I have to
say is that the story of Exodus
in many ways
embodies--crystallizes the real,
intellectual issues of
Purgatory.
What is the story of Exodus
about?
The leaving behind the house of
bondage,
as they call it,
the house of bondage,
the taking along the gold of
the Egyptians which really means
the secular knowledge.
That secular knowledge is also
part of what we must carry with
us in the journey toward
freedom.
But it also means that they
stay in the desert;
the Jews stay in the desert for
forty days.
They feel that they're
abandoned by Moses who has come
up to receive the tables of the
law, and while they're abandoned
they engage in idolatry.
This is the story of Exodus,
a story of a people caught
between idolatry and revelation
and promises,
and prophetic promises;
prophesy and idolatry.
The idolatry shows itself as a
statement or as an experience of
nostalgia: that's what the
making of the golden calf is.
A statement--a way
of--desperate as they may be,
because they are now leaderless
and they will be for a while,
then they engage in an act of
desire,
a longing for at least the
safety or what they perceive as
the safety of the dwelling in
Egypt,
mindless of the fact that they
were in bondage.
It is as if safety,
the safety of living were
preferable to them even in--
if that is the safety provided,
procured,
and in the shadow of tyranny,
of bondage.
These are the concerns that
Dante will have as he comes into
Purgatory.
The whole of Purgatorio is
literally a journey of a way of
looking back and forth between
the future and the past,
and the future and the past are
rivaling with each other for the
control of the mind of the
pilgrim.
Let's see how this is going to
be developed and I hope I have
time to go--
give you time for questions
because I'm really--
I realize that I am saying a
lot of things and there are a
lot of things I'm not even
saying.
The poem, the canto,
shifts from these grand
historical concerns,
these reflections on how the
pagan world experiences
beginnings and new departures,
only with an ideology of
freedom, and this idea,
biblical idea of a new
beginning which is really a
break with slavery,
the retrieval of the idea of
freedom in--
a general one,
in a historical way.
Now it shifts,
the narrative shifts,
and it's all internalized.
The pilgrim moves within
himself and the first statement
is that he does not know where
he is and that's an--
that is to say a way of
alluding to this exilic
predicament he has.
He literally has--he does not
know where to go.
He already had indicated that
his state of mind as that of one
who with the mind keeps going
towards someplace,
but with the body he's kept
behind.
Remember that line which
clearly dramatizes this split
with a kind of inner self
dislocation for the pilgrim and
now he just is--
now in meeting these penitent
souls,
who are as lost as he is,
about the place and they all
ask him for directions.
Which--where they are singing
"In exitu...
" they're in the desert,
the desert--to be in the
desert.
What is the desert?
The desert where one is,
the desert if you don't know
which way to go,
the desert is the unmapped
space between Egypt,
typologically speaking,
and Jerusalem.
It's some space in between.
You have no roots;
you have no paths.
There are no carvings or
markers left for you,
and so they ask him.
Can you?
Lines 6 and following:
"If you know,
show us the way to go to the
mountain.'
And Virgil answered,
'You think, perhaps we are
acquainted with this place,
but we are strangers."
That's what it means to be an
exile and that's what it means
to write this poetry of exile
that Dante will write.
This Purgatorio is this
place of the desert,
there is a spirituality even of
the desert, and certainly the
statement of the exilic
condition.
We really don't belong here.
We are always displaced and
going somewhere else and the--at
the basis of Dante's own
religious longing,
there is the sense of
displacement.
There is the sense of we are
somehow out of--that our hearts
are out of where they should be.
"We came but now,
a little while before you,
by another road which was so
rough and hard that now the
climb will seem to us as a
pastime.'
The souls, who had perceived
from my breathing that I was
still in life,
turned pale with wonder,
and as to a messenger who bears
an olive branch that people
crowed to hear the news and no
one heeds the crush,
so every one of these fortunate
souls fixed his eyes on my face
as if forgetting to go and make
themselves fair."
Now he, Dante,
becomes the object of
temptation for the penitent
souls.
They should be going somewhere,
they should be going up the
mountain and yet,
they stop where they are.
So another way of thinking
about forgetfulness and the
sense of a name,
of a place to reach.
Let's see how this is developed.
"I saw one of them come
forward with so many--so much
affection to embrace me that it
moved me to do the same.
O empty shades,
except in semblances.
Three times I clasped my hands
behind him, and as often brought
them back to my breast.
Wonder, I think,
was painted in my looks,
at which the shade smiled and
drew back and I,
following him,
pressed forward.
Gently, he bade me stand;
then I knew who it was,
and begged me that he would
stay a little and talk with
me."
This little detail of the
embrace, the failed embrace,
is one of the three failed
embraces;
a way of acknowledging for the
pilgrim an asset knowledge that
there really--the souls you have
no substantiality that we can
grasp.
This is the first,
and there will be two more that
I will talk about as we proceed.
"He answered me,
"Even as I loved thee in
my mortal flesh,
so do I love thee freed;
therefore I stay.
But thou, why are thou on this
journey?
'My Casella.'"
Dante meets a friend from his
youth, a musician,
a musician who probably had
even set to music Dante's own
poetry.
A man from Siena who clearly
has died.
So it's to relieve the hardship
of the journey.
This is apparent:
a moment of indulgence,
a way of meeting with a friend,
a little pastoral interlude if
you wish,
to break up the hardness of the
desert and the implications of
that metaphor.
The world of,
not a quest but now a pause,
the pause of reflection,
the pause of relief,
and the aesthetic relief that
this can give him.
"My Casella,
to return another time,
where I am I take this road;
but from thee how has so much
time been taken.'
And he said...
'No wrong is done me,"
he explains how he got here.
"And I:
'If a new law does not take
from thee memory or practice of
the songs of love which used to
quiet all my longings,"
this clearly is a reflection on
the power of aesthetics and on
the limits of aesthetics,
"may it please thee to
refresh my soul with them for a
while,
which he so spent coming here
with my body."
And so Casella starts singing a
song which is a poem that Dante
himself wrote and now he sets it
in music as he probably may have
done in this life.
"Love that discourses to
me in my mind,' he began then,
so sweetly, that the sweetness
sounds within me still."
Here sweetness is to be
understood as the attribute of
musical harmony.
I know the sweetness,
and I indicated this when
talking about the gluttons,
it's always the language of the
palate and the savoring,
a certain savoring that goes on
with the gluttons.
Here it's really a musical
attribute: the quality of the
sound.
And, "My Master and I and
these people who were with him
seem as content as if nothing
else touched the mind of any.
We were all rapt and attentive
to his notes,
when lo,"
Cato, "the venerable old
man,
crying: 'What is this,
laggard spirits?
What negligence,
what delay is this?
Haste to the mountain to strip
you of the slough that allows
not God to be manifest to
you."
Okay, so here is an aesthetic
enclosure.
The poet listens to his own
song, with a little touch of
narcissistic temptation,
that his Casella is playing up
to him,
reassuring him,
giving him a sense that this is
you and I know who you are.
And they're all rapt and they
forget about the ascent and then
of course Cato comes,
the ethical voice,
the voice of the law.
So you may have a kind of--you
may even want to write about
this scene as a sort of conflict
between aesthetics and ethics.
How are they working against
each other?
One thing is clear here,
that Dante is forgetful of the
real lesson that he has learned
in the encounter with Cato.
It just happened that Cato
himself--
therefore he intervenes and his
anger is the anger of the
teacher,
because he says,
I just explained to you what
the problems are.
Cato--Virgil had approached
Cato, who had hoped that Cato
could be swayed by the memory of
the past and Cato had rejected
the power of that memory.
He--the affection even and the
pleasure of that memory.
Dante comes in Canto II and
he's involved in--
let's call it even an
idolatrous moment,
the moment where he just
witnesses something that he has
been making,
that he has built,
he has composed,
is taken in by it but
essentially that has the power
to distract him from his own
ascent.
He has forgotten the reasons
why he is here in Purgatory and
so the whole of Purgatorio
begins with the explicit
statement about the importance
of new beginnings,
new departures.
The recognition that everything
new in the future can only come
out of some sense of the past
and then the discovery that the
past can interfere,
can intrude,
and therefore the steady
process of a continuous quest,
that a continuous rethinking
opens up in front of the pilgrim
and in front of us.
The interesting thing,
and here I stop,
Cato uses one word:
what kind of negligence is
this?
You know what the word means?
Negligence?
We are all negligent.
What are we when we are
negligent?
What does the word contain
since they were talking about
beginnings with--when we talk
about etymology,
which is the language of
beginnings?
Negligence means not to choose:
what Cato is reproaching Dante
and his guide,
and all the other souls,
he's reproaching the power of
poetry to produce this
atmosphere of non-choice.
And obliquely,
that's then what his ethics is,
and we are always engaged in an
act of choice.
He speaks from the perspective
of freedom which literature,
the poetic text that Dante
evokes, has the power to tame
and somehow,
for a moment,
at least here,
neutralize.
You see the extraordinary
degree of self-reflection and
self-reflexiveness of Dante,
from all points of view.
Let me stop and see if there
are questions and I hope to be
able to answer some of these
elements in the introduction of
Purgatorio.
Yes?
Student:
In the beginning of Canto I
when he talks about leaving
behind her so cluelessly and
he's talking about the bark of
his intellect leaving...
Prof: The bark of his
wit, it's called in English,
yes.
Student:
His wit--is it also a reference
to past poetry and the epic
tradition, because I read it as
sort of he's looking behind
Inferno, but it is also
reference to how he's leaving
behind and excelling a past epic
tradition?
Prof: The question is,
the metaphor,
at the beginning of
Purgatorio when the poet
says that he's leaving behind
such a cruel sea,
that cruel sea seems to be--and
is,
actually, we can agree easily,
a reference to Inferno,
but then the question is,
can it be also a reference to
past epic traditions?
It could be,
but you would have to be a
little more specific about what
you mean.
You mean the Odyssey for
instance, or the Aeneid,
journeys by sea.
Dante is--the Divine Comedy is
constantly imbricated with these
other poems.
And in fact,
the great poem that he recalls,
a past epic tradition is Lucan
and he chooses Lucan,
because Lucan is--so I'm coming
back to your question and trying
to welcome it and say that
indeed,
it's possible,
but I have to explain why I
think it's possible.
Lucan's Pharsalia is a unique
text, in the epic tradition,
because it deliberately places
itself as a historical work.
The polemic of Lucan towards
Virgil is that Virgil--
sure he had been talking about
the foundation of Rome and for
the Roman there is nothing more
historical than that--
as you know,
the Romans are the--some
practical people that will
count--
will calculate history from the
foundation of the city.
There's never a scheme about
the Garden of Eden,
or Bede who starts writing
about unknown events in the
past, or whatever.
The Roman starts with the
foundation of the city,
Livy.
So Virgil writes about the
origin of Rome and from that
point of view,
he's a historical author.
He mixes his historical
accounts as so much myth making
that Lucan rejects that form of
poetry and he writes an epic
about the civil war.
Lucan writes about Caesar and
Pompey,
which clearly is a way of
adumbrating another more
pressing civil war,
that between Antony and
Augustus, and alluding to the
one between Sulla and Marias and
the whole sequel of civil wars
that had punctuated and given
its--
it's the quality,
the distinctiveness of Roman
history.
In a way, I would say that
Dante is rejecting a certain
type of epic poetry that deals
with some kind of generalized
metaphorical account.
Though for instance,
he's going to be Jason;
he's going to be Aeneas.
Now we have to keep that in
mind.
It would be a turn to,
at least in Canto I,
a turn toward a historical
world, a way of making
Purgatory part of
history,
because that's really the
secret of Purgatory.
Purgatorio began by
saying that it's part of human
geography, do you remember?
But not of human history:
Dante wants to make it part of
human history.
We really can't go back to the
Garden of Eden,
if not directly through some
reconstruction and shadowy
refiguration,
something that looks like the
well being of the Garden of
Eden,
something like a--not really
utopia,
but something that can approach
the order of the Garden of Eden.
I must have confused you with
this answer and if so--good,
thank-you, well,
of course not.
I think that I was going five
different directions and I
apologize if I did.
Yes?
Student:
In the beginning,
you were talking about how the
journey of poetry is really
important, and so if poetry has
the power too you can work your
way to
>,
and then you were just talking
about how aesthetics can get in
the way and how that poetry can
have a mutual
>
effect.
Can you just talk a little bit
more about the tension what he
thinks the proper role of poetry
should be, what was it--let you
act and the community towards
action and then what's
>.
Prof: Yes,
great question and the question
is,
that I was--I began by talking
today about the journey of
poetry and really ended with the
idea of the danger of poetry
that aesthetics have--
confrontation that the poet
Dante has with a poet of his own
youth.
So what gives about this
tension since I'm talking about
a tension between two modes of
poetry.
I claim on the one hand that
poetry is for Dante a way of
knowing and then here seems to
get in the way,
a scandal in a sense.
It really stumble--makes him
stumble.
What is this--the connection
between these two forms?
That is really a great question.
I think that Dante understands
that, first of all,
let me just give him a great
deal of credit.
By the time Dante writes,
poetry was still by and large a
little game that the
Provençal poets were
playing in the courts of
Provence and northern Italy,
were little games about secret
love stories,
little games about hunting,
etc., or the great poems of the
so-called Goliards,
the gluttonous ones,
the belly worship.
Dante comes along and says,
no, this vernacular poetry can
really become the medium for
knowing everything that we can
humanly can know about
ourselves,
about God and about all the
things that we can--
we believe in and the things
that we would like to believe
in.
All the hopes and defeats that
we have, so that's the great
idea what it means.
From that point of view,
Dante engages poetry within
this circle of knowledge,
of what I call the encyclopedic
compass of knowledge.
So he involves all the
sciences, but at the same time,
you ask me to think about that
dialectic, one is not
conceivable without the other.
In order to really know,
the first thing that poetry has
to do is show that it knows
itself.
Usually the way--the reason why
poetry is treated as a lowly
art, because it's meretricious,
it doesn't--it gives itself to
everybody.
I'm saying all of this because
the scene of Canto II really
recalls a great scene.
We haven't got time to go into
that.
It recalls another great scene
and I think that Dante's really
rethinking the famous opening
scene of Boethius,
The Consolation of Philosophy,
which I don't know if you have
read,
but I have mentioned it,
but you will.
You look like someone who would
go to the library now and pick
up the--it's really a book--no
I'm serious.
It's really a book where the
philosopher is sick in bed.
He is--he does not know he's
diseased.
In order to find comfort he
picks up a book of poetry,
the muses go to him.
It's a book of poetry which
probably is what most people
would do if they got the flu.
It's time to read good poetry,
right?
Then all of a sudden,
Lady Philosophy appears and
banishes these muses,
get thee hence you harlots,
he calls them,
of the theatre because you
don't give any real remedy,
you just only provide
provisional solace.
What Dante is doing is--the
whole of the Boethius is
philosophy is really better than
poetry,
a way of recasting the old
Platonic quarrel as we know from
even the Republic,
right, between--the debate
between poetry and philosophy.
What Dante is doing is--no,
no, poetry may have these
dangerous temptations and
possibilities but that's what
makes it part of its own
self-knowledge.
I want to--I cannot guarantee
or promise that poetry will lead
you to knowledge,
unless I show that the medium
that I use,
knows itself,
it knows its own temptations.
It knows its own meretricious
possibilities,
you see what I'm saying?
It always accompanies one--he
says, you want me to highlight
the reasons of that dialectic,
that tension.
And the only answer that I can
give is that one flanks the
other constantly,
so that the voice of Cato and
the voice of Casella there,
at the same time they belong,
necessarily belong together in
the unfolding and the
articulation of Dante's own
voice.
This is--you cannot expect to
have one say,
well then if this is really
dangerous, can I have something
else?
No it's not either-or,
it's both-and.
The either-or,
the ethical or aesthetic and
ethical, as if there were two
opposed forms just will not do.
Okay, other questions?
I wish you had another hour
here, so that I could really
talk about some of these details
in the beginning of the poem.
Well since I hear none--no
other questions,
thank you.
See you next time.